THAT.
WELL, RAPPER AND ENTERTAINER
KANYE WEST APPEARED ON THE
DAVID LETTERMAN NETFLIX SHOW
AND WHILE THERE HE SAID
SOMETHING PRETTY TRUE.
OBVIOUSLY TRUE BUT SAID IT OUT
LOUD.
THE AMERICAN LEFT SUDDENLY
DECIDED TO BULLY THE REST OF
US.
CONSTANTLY.
WATCH.
>> HAVE YOU EVER BEEN BEAT UP
IN YOUR HIGH SCHOOL FOR
WEARING THE WRONG HAT?
>> I AM BEAT UP BECAUSE PEOPLE
DIDN'T LIKE ME.
[LAUGHTER]
I KNOW WHAT YOU ARE SAYING.
>> THE IDEA IS THE BULLYING.
>> WHO IS THE BULLY IN THE
SCENARIO?
>> DEFINITELY LIBERALS BULLY
PEOPLE WHO ARE TRUMP
SUPPORTERS.
IT'S NOT JUST CALM.
YOU CAN'T JUST GO AND WEAR THE
HAT.
YOU CAN'T JUST GO.
IT'S LIKE [bleep]
[bleep]
BRO!
>> Tucker: AUTHOR AND
COLUMNIST MARK STEYN OFTEN
WEARS THE HAT AND CAN SPEAK
DIRECTLY TO DO THIS.
GOOD TO SEE YOU.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THIS?
>> I LOVE THESE LITTLE, AS YOU
SAID, HE GOES AWAY AND THEN HE
COMES BACK.
LOOK, I DON'T REALLY LIKE THE
IDEA OF EXPANDING THE
ENCYCLOPEDIA OF THE REPUBLICAN
CELEBRITIES.
AS FAR AS I KNOW IT HAS PAT
BOONE AND ONE OF THE OAK RIDGE
BOYS IN IT.
FINE BY ME.
IT'S ABOUT THE GROUP THINK.
THAT IS WHAT HE IS ON THEM.
HE DOESN'T THINK WHAT HE
SHOULD GET TOLD THE PARAMETERS
IN WHICH HE CAN THINK.
THAT IS WHAT IS SO SAD AND
PATHETIC.
ABOUT THE CELEBRITIES.
THEY THINK THEY ARE EDGY AND
TRANSGRESSIVE.
THEY ARE THE LEAST EDGY AND
THE LEAST TRANSGRESSION OF THE
CELEBRITIES EVER EXISTED
BECAUSE THEY ARE TERRIFIED TO
MOVE 16th OF AN INCH
OUTSIDE THE PARAMETERS.
HE IS SAYING LOOK, I'M ONE OF
THE RICHEST, THE MOST
SUCCESSFUL CELEBRITIES ON THE
PLANET WHY CAN'T I THINK
CONTRARIANLY OCCASIONALLY.
>> Tucker: THEY ARE THE
OBEDIENT LEMMINGS EVER.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
>> Tucker: WHAT WOULD TRULY
TRANSGRESSIVE LOOK LIKE IN
2019?
>> I THINK TRULY TRANSGRESSIVE
ACTUALLY WOULD BE THINKING
OUTSIDE THE BOX.
THE HOLLYWOOD BOX ON SOMETHING
LIKE IMMIGRATION OR DIVERSITY
OR ANY OF THE CLICHE
OR ANY OF THE CLICHÉS OF THE
AGE.
IT'S VERY, ACTUALLY IT'S VERY
SAD WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
COUNTER CULTURE FIGURES.
COUNTERCULTURE HAS TO HAVE A
CULTURE TO BE COUNTER TO.
AND THE COUNTER CULTURE DID
SUCH A GOOD JOB THAT IT IS NOW
THE ESTABLISHMENT, AND IT
CAN'T BEAR TO SEE IT ITSELF
LIKE THAT.
WHICH IS WHY YOU HAVE ROBERT
DINERO BECAUSE HE WON.
HE HAS NOTHING TO PUSH AGAINST
ANYMORE.
AND KANYE WEST, I THINK, IS
JUST SAYING COULDN'T WE AT
LEAST RECOGNIZE THAT THE
CELEBRITY LIFE IS MORE FUN,
BORING HOLLYWOOD DINNER
PARTIES WOULD BE FOR FUN IF WE
AT LEAST ALLOWED TWO SIDES TO
EVERY ISSUE.
INSTEAD OF JUST -- AS YOU HAD
MENTIONED, DRONING ON ABOUT
CLIMATE CHANGE AND SAVING THE
PLANET.
IMAGINE HOW BORING THAT WOULD
BE AT A HOLLYWOOD BEVERLY
HILLS?
WOULDN'T IT BE GREAT IF KANYE
OR ONE OF HIS PALS SAID I
DON'T THINK IT'S SUCH A BIG
DEAL.
BUT THEY ARE NOT ALLOWED TO
SAY THAT.
>> Tucker: IT MAKES THEM
REALLY MAD WHEN YOU SAY.
THAT I'VE DONE THAT.
PEOPLE DON'T LIKE THAT.
>> YEAH, NO, THEY DON'T.
>> Tucker: THERE IS ONLY ONE
SIDE.
>> THAT MAKES BORING ART,
BORING POP CULTURE.
WHETHER OR NOT HE IS
BOPPINGERS I LOVE HIM FOR